this is a production of cornell
university
i bet you're thinking to yourself what
can i do to avoid the living sculpture
graveyard
well you're in luck it's simple all you
need to do is some basic advanced
planning
every living sculpture project needs
some planning that takes into account
the following two principles
one maintenance of the sculpture
and two youth and community involvement
in the project
living sculpture is easy to create and
with a little time devoted to
maintaining it
each week it will be a terrific addition
to your community
each type of living sculpture requires
unique forms of maintenance
for example sod sculptures need to be
watered each day for two weeks
until the piece is established and then
weekly thereafter
once the sod has grown in they need to
be routinely trimmed down
so it's a good idea to keep on hand the
basic supplies you need
such as the garden hose and pruning
shears
a second critical part of your project
planning will be to ensure
youth and community involvement make
sure that you involve and engage
youth and community members in all
stages of the project
from planning and design to creation and
maintenance
remember that people take care of what
they own and of what they love
including living sculpture
if these two basic principles of
maintenance and youth and community
involvement
are taken into account in your project
then there's no doubt
your living sculpture will be a popular
thriving place to hang out in your
community
for years to come enjoy
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu